Four years ago, we started to wonder.
What would shopping look like if you could walk into a store...
...grab what you want and just go?
What if we can weave the most advanced machine learning, computer vision and AI...
...into the very fabric of a store so you never have to wait in line?
No lines, no checkouts, no registers.
Welcome to Amazon Go.
Use the Amazon Go app to enter.
Then put away your phone and start shopping.
So, how does it work?
We use computer vision, deep learning algorithms, and sensor fusion,...
...much like you'd find in self-driving cars.
We call it "Just walk out" technology.
Once you've got everything you want, you can just go.
When you leave, our "Just Walk Out" technology adds up your virtual cart...
....and charges your Amazon account.
Your receipt is sent straight to the app and you can keep going.
Amazon Go.
No lines.
No checkout.
No, seriously.